a new book explores the challenges of
modern boyhood and it argues
our approach to raising boys has failed
and the time now is to change it to
raise a boy classrooms
locker rooms bedrooms and the hidden
struggles of american boyhood
is published by atria it's an imprint of
simon schuster which is a division of
vicom cbs it's an important book though
author and washington post reporter emma
brown says
that in the wake of the metoo movement
she wanted to know
how will i raise my son to be different
and she joins us now for an interview
you were seeing first on cbs this
morning emma good morning to you
uh so we talk a lot on this show about
what men do
to each other to women but we don't
spend much time thinking about
why men are the way they are and this
book does that it comes along at exactly
the right time and i was hoping you
could begin
by just telling viewers what it was you
thought was missing from your
parental toolkit when you looked down at
your son gus and thought
how am i going to do this well thank you
i
you know when my daughter was born three
years before my son
i had such strong gut instincts about
how i wanted to parent her
to resist the messages that get beamed
at girls from the time that they're born
and i realized i had none of those gut
instincts for my son because
i have never been a boy and you know i
had never
really even grappled with the idea that
boys face pressures or stresses in the
way that girls do
and so this book was a chance for me to
explore that yeah it's interesting that
you know you think that certain things
are innately different between boys and
girls but
to a large extent they come out the same
and then it's things that we teach them
that make them different and actually
i'll give you a really good example from
my household this week
my son teddy's favorite book currently
is a book called
boys dance it's by the american ballet
theater
it's about boys doing ballet but as your
book points out as we all know
at a certain point he will start school
and he'll start getting this message
that certain things maybe even ballet
is girly and not for him what are
parents supposed to do to stop that
process
yeah i mean i think you know shame is a
really corrosive force
and boys get shamed for doing anything
that is seen to be girly and that is one
of the
ingredients that i think is um is
you know adds up to pretty poor outcomes
for men in america
both in terms of physical and mental
health boy so many boys told me
um that they were told by their parents
never to cry because they're boys and so
when we tell boys to
shut off the parts of themselves that
are human uh
that is you know that's that's how we
end up with
um men who die by suicide at four times
the rate of women
shorter lives for men um boys are really
struggle
and we need to help them and as you say
parents need help from the institutions
that help raise our sons
including schools sports teams faith
communities
absolutely yeah help boys become a
complete person as you argue
consent is obviously a big issue parents
know
that you've got to teach the difference
between yes and no
but it's more complicated you have a
phrase in the book uh that
no is not always spelled n-o
explain that absolutely well you know
what
a boy a young man i met um
a college man told me the way we talk
about consent gets translated to boys
like this he says you teach us no means
no and that teach just
teaches us we need to get her to say yes
get the
girl we're with to say yes and um and
that is exactly what you're talking
about you know girls um
girls and boys express themselves
verbally and non-verbally
and so if we're not careful the way that
we talk about consent can just
teach boys um to to ignore some of the
non-verbal
signs that they get uh that are very
that can be very clear
um and instead just sort of look for a
way to
coerce or pressure so we've got to find
a new way to talk about
what consent is and it's about listening
right it's about listening to the person
you're with and respecting
what you hear from them whether you hear
that verbally or non-verbally
emma part of the reason i really endorse
this book for parents even though it's
not a parenting book is because it
helped you come up with a mantra an idea
for how you wanted to raise your son
so for your daughter you were telling
her strong and fearless
for your son you came up with strong and
gentle
i love that yeah you know
i i feel like it gives him access to the
best parts of what we
traditionally think of as feminine and
the best parts of what we have
traditionally thought of as masculine
and he should have access to the best of
both of those worlds
all right if you're a parent and you're
anxious about raising a boy in this
world this book will take your
temperature down i endorse it emma brown
thank you very much for being here we
appreciate it to raise a boy
is on sale right now